اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الجويه الروسيه والصينيه نفذت دوريات
مشتركه في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
واكدت الوزاره في بيان ان دوريه المشتركه
تاتي في اطار خطه التعاون العسكري بين
البلدين العام الجاري وليست مواجهه ضد احد
واوضحتا حاملات الصواريخ استراتيجيه
الروسيه وقذفات صينيه استراتيجيه حلقت فوق
المياه الاقليميه لبحر اليابان وبحر الصين
الشرقي والجزء الغربي من المحيط الهادئ
قال منسق للبيت الابيض لمنطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ كورت كامبلن العلاقه بين
روسيا والصين بشان اوكرانيا مقلقه واضاف
المسؤول الامريكي ان بلاده تريد ان تلعب
بجين دورا دبلوماسيا مسؤولا حسب وصفه
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
ان العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه تواجه
حاليا تحديات لكن المسؤوليه لا تقع على
عاتق بلاده واضاف وانجا على الجانب
الامريكي احترام المصالح الاساسيه لبيجين
وتوقف عن التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه وعدم
الاضرار بمصالحها
حافظنا على الاتصالات الضروريه مع
الولايات المتحده تواجه العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه حاليا تحديات لكن المسؤوليه لا
تقع على عاتقنا يجب على واشنطن ان تحترم
مصالحنا الاساسيه ومخاوفنا الرئيسيه وان
تتوقف عن التدخل في شؤوننا الداخليه
والاضرار بمصالحنا وان تكفا عن قول شيء
وفعل شيء اخر علينا العمل معا لدفع
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه الى المسار
الصحيح